welcome folks how are you doing today
we're gonna get you up to speed on how
to get good with the legend that is
Pathfinder uh Pathfinder is definitely
my favorite sassy robot boy he's got
this really cool feature where he can
tell you where the next circles gonna be
he's quick he's fast he's nimble he's
agile and he's great at helping out
teammates with all of his abilities if
used in the right way he's also the most
titanfall character for people who were
concerned about mobility in apex
originally Pathfinder is your robot to
do the most titanfall style movement of
any other legend in this game and we'll
do that movement using the grappling
hook which brings us to our first
tactical yeah so the grappling hook the
thing with the grappling hook is you're
doing it wrong at least when you start
off you're gonna do it wrong it's a
tactical that needs a lot of practice
because what initially happens is you go
from point A to point B and you don't
realize that you can actually whip or
launch yourself with it yeah it's not a
straight line like a like a Widowmaker
and overwatch or something like that you
can you can mess with it there physics
to it you can move around so how you do
this is you fire the grappling hook you
wait for it to attach the object you'll
hear a grabbing sound on the second you
hear that sound you need to time that
with the jump button and as it picks you
up if you do it right you'll actually go
up into the air as opposed to just
straight
yeah gives you like a little boost and
you can actually then when you're in the
air kind of adjust which way you're
going using forward and strafe and it
will cause you to loop out which way
you're actually pushing and you can
continue to stay attached if you track
with your look on your mouse or use a
very right stick and that will actually
let you either orbit stuff if you want
to or just completely let go if you look
away so that slingshot maneuver becomes
you absolute go-to maneuvering gunfights
it basically lets you get places that
people don't expect you usually behind
them so you can go up in over rocks or
you can whip around buildings or you can
whip up and over the top of cover unlike
some of the even the larger pieces of
cover yeah yeah or simply just fire
yourself off down a steep hill and just
get away real quick it's it's all leads
into speed or flanking just being in
places where people don't expect you to
be which is definitely is
longest point the downside of the
grappling hook is then over-commitment
yes apex is a game with a long time to
kill and it's really hard to win one v2s
much less one VIII's so whipping
yourself into a position where you're
behind a team is great if they don't
know you're there and if they do know
you're there you're probably gonna lose
so be very careful about what situations
you get yourself into and how much
further ahead of your team you want to
get at any given time I feel like that
almost any time when I'm playing I'll
actually stick behind so that everyone
actually moves up ahead of me and then
that's when I'll come in and swoop
either around to the side or up and over
them to kind of just get to a place
where the people aren't looking that's a
good point wait until the other team is
distracted before making your move
because they're gonna be too
concentrated on oh there's someone here
we can't do anything we've got to mark
them and start shooting them to even
notice that you're already up in the air
and you're coming down with your
peacemaker shotgun all loaded and ready
to go the other thing you can do is get
away from things
so Ultimates from Gibraltar and
Bangalore usually blanket an area with
hot death and the grappling hooks just a
good way to get out when you need to
yeah it's great for escaping great for
getting in it's versatile now for the
prestige if you want to you can grab
somebody with a grappling hook and
dropkick them I don't necessarily
recommend it but it does look damn cool
if you pull it off it's entirely worth
it if you can if you can land it it
looks really cool and really badass and
I'm still not gonna hit myself but one
day I'll get there hey at least you
tried exactly
moving along
Pathfinder's passive is insider
knowledge so this is where you hack
survey beacons around the map they show
up on your mini-map if you pull it up as
like little T's and they're usually
somewhere up high that only somebody
with a grappling hook can get to exactly
you walk up to them you press a button
and after a bit of an animation where
you're vulnerable but I've never really
had a problem with it you'll see where
the next circle is gonna be that
sometimes is useful sometimes it's right
next to you but that information can
give your team better decision-making
skills yeah always knowing where you're
gonna be heading next is a huge benefit
especially in a game like a battle
royale where the area keeps getting
smaller and smaller
you only suppose the downside is the
fact that it makes a giant sound that
people like three towns over can hear
but it doesn't really do anything cuz no
one tracks down who just hit the button
people either don't know what it is or
it's just not noticeable enough I've
never had somebody come after me I've
never had any issues with it either but
just as a heads-up it makes up very loud
noise and if you hear it you'll know
what happened so now you know where the
next circle is gonna be it's time to
pull out your ultimate which is the
zipline gun the zipline gun is another
tool to get you and your team now to
places that other teams can't be
particularly taking the high ground
crossing chasms getting behind people or
just again getting out of a bad
situation yeah I like using it for us
especially getting up on top of things
on top of buildings making escape routes
if we need to get out of some plates
quick or I'll even use it like to help
people get out of say if we were in the
closing circle and people need to catch
up or we need to cover a lot of ground
really quickly just putting one down on
the flat ground to move quicker and you
can do that because the cooldown is so
very quick on it yeah this is not an
ultimate that is meant to be held on to
you're supposed to use this constantly
it recharges fairly quickly and you're
just gonna be a much more effective team
if you're constantly moving
another thing that lets you do is hang
away further back as the circle closes
so like now that you know where the next
circle is gonna be and how far that
distance is and you have several
mobility options one of which can take
your team with you hang back let other
teams get there ahead of you start
killing each other and then
you can zipline in way later and mop up
exactly you know side note sometimes
good zipline placement in the last
circle can mean that your team wins even
though you're dead so you know be kind
zip line exactly always put them down
whenever you can all right final
thoughts on Pathfinder Ben so the
biggest thing is always beware people
don't expect you to be up and around
things up and over things on top of
things places that you would never look
and he's so strong at it it's my
favorite part about him besides the fact
that he's just a real quick little robot
boy who's always happy yeah just
practice practice practice on that
grappling hook until you get good at it
and I promise you will see some some
massive gains with this character we're
just getting started with what apex can
do so head on over to GameSpot to share
your favorite legend and maybe some
things that we don't know if it's cool
enough hey it might end up in the next
video all right thanks for dropping in
everyone tweet me your cool zipline
kicks I want to see all your zipline
kicks show me all of your cool
Pathfinder plays
[Music]
[Music]